[Música]
finalizó la novena cumbre de las
américas dejando un mal sabor de boca
será recordada por las ausencias de
varios países que no fueron convocados
también deja en evidencia las fracturas
que hay en el continente americano justo
cuando la unión es lo que más se
necesita y también dejó en evidencia esa
pérdida de influencia que tiene eeuu en
la región de américa latina' una
influencia que trató de comenzar a
recuperar a partir de esta cumbre la
pregunta es si ese primer paso dado por
eeuu fue positivo o no veamos más
detalles en el siguiente informe
una apuesta continental para hacer
frente a una creciente crisis migratoria
los líderes de naciones de américa del
norte del sur y centroamérica se
reunieron en los ángeles esta semana
durante la cumbre de las américas es el
tema central de este año fue la
migración el gobierno de joe biden
impulsó la adopción de una hoja de ruta
para los países de acogida y tránsito de
los migrantes y refugiados en la región
entonces con esta declaración estamos
transformando nuestro enfoque de la
gestión de la migración en las américas
cada uno de nosotros está firmando
compromisos que reconocen los desafíos
que todos compartimos la responsabilidad
de los impactos de todas nuestras
naciones grace jones al final 20 de las
35 naciones del continente firmaron iba
a ir en espera que haya más apoyos en el
futuro la declaración de los ángeles se
basa en cuatro pilares vías legales para
los trabajadores extranjeros ayuda a las
comunidades que acogen a los migrantes
una gestión más humana de las fronteras
y respuestas coordinadas de emergencia
la decisión de washington de excluir a
venezuela cuba y nicaragua
basándose en prácticas antidemocráticas
llevo a varios países entre ellos el
vecino directo de eeuu méxico a enviar
al canciller marcelo ebrard en reemplazo
del presidente andrés manuel lópez
obrador
tenemos ahora mismo unos resultados de
la cumbre que son muy positivos desde
nuestro punto de vista desde el punto de
vista de front max holder contribuir sin
embargo méxico alabó el resultado final
la política de migración de washington
se ha centrado durante mucho tiempo a
contener la migración irregular a través
de su frontera sur pero en los últimos
años se ha producido un fenómeno
creciente en todo el hemisferio
occidental ya que millones de
venezolanos huyen del colapso económico
hacia los países vecinos colombia
ecuador y perú cientos de miles de
nicaragüenses son empujados por la
persecución política hacia costa rica y
un número incalculable de
centroamericanos se refugian de la
violencia de las pandillas trasladándose
a méxico oa estados unidos
la migración sin duda alguna era el tema
central de esta cumbre tema importante
para la región pero sobre todo para la
casa blanca en pleno año electoral
en este tema 20 países firmaron la
declaración de los ángeles que busca que
los países no hagan frente al problema
de la migración de manera solitaria y
haya un apoyo en conjunto que tanto se
va a lograr esto ya lo veremos más
adelante con nuestros analistas también
busca una migración legal y también la
devolución de los migrantes que están en
situación irregular pero justamente los
países que no asistieron o que no
enviaron a sus presidentes son las
naciones que tal vez les interesaría más
este tema estamos hablando de países
como el salvador guatemala venezuela
honduras y cuba
justamente el no haber invitado a cuba
venezuela nicaragua generó una atmósfera
enrarecida en esta cumbre se perdió
entonces una oportunidad de acercamiento
entre washington y estos países fomentar
el diálogo entre las partes podía haber
sido algo propicio en esta cumbre
tampoco gustó el boicot del presidente
mexicano andrés manuel lópez obrador la
ausencia de varios jefes de estado para
muchos de heres peso político a esta
cumbre también hubo tiempo para firmar
la alianza para la prosperidad de las
américas todo esto para la protección de
los océanos algo que pasó desapercibido
entre la prensa y también entre los
asistentes solamente siete países
firmaron este compromiso que nos deja
entonces esta novena edición de la
cumbre de las américas fueron o serán
fructíferos esos esfuerzos de eeuu por
acercarse a la región como es entonces
el papel de eeuu y américa latina en
este momento dada las relaciones que hay
hay liderazgos destacables en nuestra
región es posible buscar una estrategia
en conjunto para hacer frente al tema de
la migración que fue el tema central hay
muchas preguntas muchos temas para
analizar aquí en el debate de france 24
sobre las conclusiones que dejó esta
novena cumbre de las américas pues para
conversar sobre este tema saludamos a
cynthia arnson ella es directora del
programa latinoamericanas del wilson
center en la ciudad de washington ella
precisamente está allí en la capital
estadounidense y también se conecta a
esta conversación a manolo préstamo él
es internacionalista investigador y
consejero migratorio entra en la ciudad
de mexico ustedes nuestros televidentes
también hacen parte de esta conversación
estamos a través de las diferentes redes
sociales ustedes ya las conocen en
facebook en instagram en twitter y
también pueden ver nuestra señal en
streaming a través de youtube nos
encuentran como france24 guión bajo s
también a santi logo que es mi cuenta
personal nuestra etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 esperamos todos sus
comentarios conclusiones y preguntas en
torno a este tema comienzo entonces
dándole la bienvenida a cynthia en la
ciudad de washington gracias por
acompañarnos en el programa y me gusta
llamar a la primera pregunta el punto de
partida para este debate y ese punto de
partida en esta oportunidad son sus
conclusiones de lo que dejó esta cumbre
de las américas en la ciudad de los
ángeles luego ya iremos profundizando en
los diferentes temas que tenemos para
abordar cynthia bienvenida bueno muchas
gracias y muchas gracias por la
invitación
creo que el resumen
se puede decir que el vaso es medio
vacío o medio lleno
para la administración baile fue un
encuentro importante un cambio de
perspectiva importante pero para para
muchos hay una gran decepción que los
planteamientos las declaraciones hechas
fueron una articulación de principios
más que nada no hubo
compromisos concretos incluso lo que
usted acaba de señalar la propuesta
migratoria
el acuerdo de los ángeles es una serie
de
principios y no es necesariamente un
compromiso firme ni por eeuu ni por los
otros países de la región
entonces yo creo que al final
pues toda la controversia sobre la
invitación o la invitación a cuba
nicaragua venezuela
dominó los titulares acerca de la de la
cumbre la
decisión de lópez obrador y de otros
presidentes de hacer boicot también
fueron parte de
los titulares y esto quita impacto y
atención a lo que realmente sucedió
durante la cumbre opinión de cynthia
arnson nuestra invitación de washington
paso ahora a ciudad de méxico allí se
encuentra manolo préstamo manolo
bienvenido al programa gracias por
acompañarnos misma pregunta como punto
de partida sus conclusiones sus
perspectivas de lo que deja esta novena
cumbre de las américas
hola santiago antes que nada muchas
veces por la invitación y compartir el
espacio con cynthia también por tanto en
el wilson center para la región creo que
sí creo que al tener el día por más de
que celebro que el tema migratorio se
centre en este tipo de foros
continentales que celebra de sur a norte
hay que recalcar eso creo que si se
fracasó en conseguir una postura
regional ante los desafíos que enfrenta
el continente creo que venimos de una de
'el por así decirlo desprestigio
desinterés por parte cada vez más de los
países de la región principalmente vemos
en eeuu en 2018 que no asistió a la
cumbre en lima hoy el presidente by the
end desde su toma de protesta habla de
una nueva y una nueva visión que tiene
para el mundo de reposición el liderazgo
de eeuu de eeuu a nivel internacional a
través empezando con latinoamérica
siendo principalmente su socio más
importante clave y estratégico que es
méxico y desde el principio vimos cómo
dejó de existir esta sinergia ante el
presidente de byd en el administración
de lópez obrador cada uno con sus
propias con sus propios claroscuros
principalmente el presidente
obrador que ya viene con esta narrativa
de desde la reunión en la celda del año
pasado que fue ser va en mexico que él
se proclama como este líder ideológico y
político de la región y él entiende que
más allá de los desde los desacuerdos
que existen por temas democráticos de
derechos humanos de regímenes es en este
caso es de dictaduras puede llamar de
ciertos países pero él entiende que lo
más importante es construir consensos
para bien o para mal cómo podemos
entender esto y el presidente de bailén
no no no da apertura no dio apertura a
esto en la narrativa en lugar de
centrarnos en los problemas del
calentamiento global de los desplazados
de la migración de la emergencia
climática de salir de la recesión que
trajo el cob y del
la desigualdad entre entre las vacunas
pues básicamente lo que llevó la
narrativa fue este debate entre el
boicot que presenta el gobierno mexicano
y no enfocarnos en los desafíos que
afrontamos en la región cynthia lo
mencionábamos tal vez lo que deja esto
en cuanto a
acuerdos es esta declaración de los
ángeles sobre migración y protección ya
explicábamos más o menos de qué se trata
es para que los países
no tengan que asumir las
responsabilidades solo sobre todo países
que tienen dificultades económicas para
poder hacer frente a la gran llegada
masiva sobre todo de venezolanos en el
caso de suramérica y para que se
enfrente esto en conjunto entre todos
los países y también una forma eeuu de
evitar que lleguen tantas personas a su
territorio en sus impresiones sobre esta
declaración en un momento en el que tal
parece que la región está tan polarizada
y tan unida en tantos temas y hay tantos
desacuerdos y discrepancias
en los puntos de vista se podrá trabajar
en conjunto para hacer frente al tema de
la migración a partir de este acuerdo de
los ángeles
yo creo que algo importante que dejó
esta declaración fue justamente que la
sensación de que la migración no es
solamente un asunto de la frontera entre
méxico y eeuu como usted acaba de
señalar los 6 millones de venezolanos
que tenían que huir de su país los
nicaragüenses que salen para costa rica
yo sé la gente de áfrica de muchas
partes que
usan el territorio panameño justamente
para llegar al norte bueno eso es un
fenómeno regional y al fin y al cabo la
migración es una política doméstica y
depende mucho también de el entorno
político en cada uno de los países los
estados unidos han donado es el
principal donante a la región para
atender a las necesidades de los
migrantes venezolanos casi dos mil
millones de dólares
pero no es suficiente sabemos
y tampoco resuelve el desacuerdo en eeuu
sobre cómo y cuántos y de qué forma se
va a admitir nuevos migrantes el número
que anunció el presidente de bailén en
esa declaración de 22 mil es de lejos un
número muy inferior a la demanda al
número de migrantes que buscan entrar en
eeuu mensualmente entonces vamos a ver
en qué forma la política doméstica en
cada uno de los países receptor de
migrantes
toma estas estos principios para
convertirlo en política pública real
clara no lo han criticado mucho al
presidente de eeuu joe biden por haber
hecho esta propuesta de este plan de
migración en conjunto con los demás
países por estar precisamente en un año
electoral desde su punto de vista esto
que tanto tiene tinte político de tinte
estratégico de cara a esas elecciones de
medio término y si de verdad es una
propuesta viable como ya lo decía ante
un continente que está muy dividido en
cuanto a el manejo que se le tiene que
dar al tema de la migración nadie quiere
hacerse responsable de absolutamente
nada tal vez el único país que ha tomado
algo de iniciativa ahí sería colombia al
ayudar a regularizar a casi 1.2 millones
de venezolanos
creo que ya lo mencionaba cintia y aquí
lo que más me preocupa que estos son
este acuerdos no vinculantes y que
dependen en 100% de las políticas
domésticas de cada uno de los estados
firmantes qué quiere decir esto que a
pesar de que la migración fue el tema
principal de la cumbre las américas se
continúa y no se no se regionaliza el
tema de la migración al dejar de lado a
los países que principalmente son
azotados por estos problemáticas tema de
nicaragua tema del salvador vemos este
cada vez más como méxico sigue
militarizando sus fronteras continúa
criminalizando la migración entonces yo
creo que a pesar de que en el discurso
el presidente va a ir en evoca las
elecciones porque no es nada este
ingeniero presidente hoy vemos que de
acuerdo a instituciones como el pri
research center ellos dicen que el 84%
de los votantes republicanos desaprueba
en la política vaivén principalmente en
temas migratorios y de esto y sobre los
los demócratas y este votantes
independientes se ha aumentado entre un
8 y un 12 por ciento
las deportaciones masivas cada vez de
estas políticas positivas en favor cada
vez más en los votantes estadounidenses
entonces claramente las elecciones están
jugando un papel fundamental en el tema
migratoria ahora creo que pues es muy
triste porque al final del día nosotros
este analizamos y leemos cada vez cifras
de deportaciones de desapariciones
principalmente en méxico pero nos
olvidamos de que estas son personas que
no están migrando por necesidad propia
no son y no está en mi vida no están
mirando por por querer por poco por éste
por nadie nadie emigra por gusto propio
de ellos migran porque están escapando
de condiciones precarias y que ningún
ninguno de estos países está tomando la
decisión este es un problema regional ya
pesar de que se diga que estamos
desarrollando para el futuro que estamos
combatiendo las causas de fondo hoy en
día miles y miles de inmigrantes y de
personas desplazadas se encuentran
atravesando el centroamérica sudamérica
hoy en día méxico y se enfrentan a
problemas no estatales como narcotráfico
como desapariciones forzadas como
inseguridad hoy en día rápidamente un
dato este recuerdo que organizaciones
internacionales como manuel wise el día
que al día de hoy en méxico más de 10
mil inmigrantes han sido han sido este
víctimas de tortura de desapariciones
forzadas y de violencia extrema entonces
es lo que me preocupa que a pesar de que
haya una posicionamiento conjunto en la
como las américas todos dependen de las
políticas internas de los países y no se
está haciendo un concepto internacional
para actuar de fondo para atender esta
situación si manolo continuó con usted
para hacer la ronda a la inversa cintia
ya le voy a dar la palabra me lleva a
preguntarle manolo que por primera vez
eeuu plantea una campaña sin precedentes
para poder desarticular y también poder
desmantelar esas redes de tráfico de
personas porque es que la migración por
lo menos en el caso centroamericano o
bueno en el continente americano viene
ligado a otros problemas graves que
tiene la región que es el narcotráfico y
estas mafias que existen en los
diferentes países
que se puede empezar a adelantar y en
cuanto a ese plan pero no a nivel de la
frontera méxico-eeuu sino como usted
dice en los países de origen en colombia
en venezuela en haití en y en los países
del triángulo del norte
creo que la situación es muy compleja
antes veíamos antes de la pandemia
porque también es un tema que creo que
ha faltado este la recuperación post
pandémica también es un tema de la
desigualdad de la de mecanismos para
solventar estas problemáticas también es
en un tema que tenemos que tratar creo
que ante o la pandemia veamos países
como brasil como chile como argentina
que asumían y absorbía en estos flujos
migratorios principalmente de haitianos
posteriormente la pandemia han dejado de
aceptar a estas personas y estas
personas han aumentado este ya ya ya
este continuo sus procesos de migración
hasta la frontera del sur de tapachula
en méxico hasta la frontera norte con
estados unidos hoy en día hablamos de un
plan de desarrollo integral que busca
atender las causas migratorias
principalmente ahí sí hay que reconocer
el papel del gobierno mexicano como a
través de problemas sociales ha
extendido los programas que se han
implementado en méxico para para
aplicarlos a temas en sudamérica y en
centroamérica vemos cómo se va a
impulsar a esta a través de la agencia
es como amexcid como yo state a
empresarios a emprendedores a
estudiantes a reactivar estas estas
comunidades originarias para que se
siente de que dejen de emigrar ahora una
cosa es hablar de reactivación económica
y otra cosa es atender el problema de
inseguridad que vive en estos países y
si es estamos viendo y quiero tomar a
este trae este problema de que había en
eeuu que es la proliferación de armas
gran parte de los tiroteos y de las
cuestiones sociales que sufre estados
unidos también la industria armamentista
vende armas de manera ilegal a méxico a
centroamérica de sudamérica y esto para
qué sirve para auspiciar a carteles
mexicanos a carteles sudamericanos
principalmente en colombia en venezuela
y hasta que yo le pongamos un alto y
hasta que nuestros jefes de estado no le
den un alto a las industrias
armamentistas a los intereses de muchos
de los de los diputados y representantes
senadores que que son impulsados por
estas industrias nuestra reunión va a
seguir sufriendo y vamos a continuar
viéndolos y migratorios aumentar en
nuestras fronteras
cintia justamente el tema de seguridad
se habló muy poco y es un tema
transversal para todos los países ya
vemos los problemas de seguridad que han
empezado a tener países debido al
narcotráfico a la aparición de bandas
delincuenciales estoy hablando de caso
ecuador que está viviendo un tema de
inseguridad muy complicado sobre todo en
la ciudad de guayaquil venezuela también
está en la misma línea y costa rica
también ha tenido varios problemas de
seguridad recientemente que no se trató
el tema de seguridad no fue pasó a un
segundo plano por debajo de la migración
de acuerdo habían unos eventos lo que se
llama los airlines sobre este tema pero
yo creo que para tiraron la pelota hacia
el futuro diciendo que va a haber una
cumbre de alcaldes
auspiciado por eeuu en el estado de
colorado justamente para hablar de estos
temas lo que quisiera añadir o sea para
cambiar un poco de tema es que para mí
una una posibilidad una oportunidad pero
también una decepción es la falta de
planes reales para ayudar a la
región económicamente para recuperar el
incremento de pobreza en desigualdad
durante la pandemia y ahora causado por
la inflación y los altos precios de
comida etcétera
en su discurso la primera noche el
presidente vaya mencionó
la necesidad de asegurar las cadenas de
valor hacerlos más seguros
pero evitó mencionar la palabra en el
swing que significa que las empresas
ahora instaladas en acción en china van
a regresar para invertir en eeuu o
también en los países no sólo méxico que
ya tiene pues muchas cadenas de valor
sin hogar de enfermería el caribe
colombia etcétera y no hubo nada
concreto entonces yo creo que el desafío
hacia el futuro es
concretizar este estos grandes anuncios
y planes que se hicieron ante la cumbre
para cerrar este tema migratorio
y pasar a otros que tengo aquí en la
agenda y cintia siempre criticaron por
lo menos desde la región latinoamericana
esa actitud paternalista que tenía eeuu
que tenía que meterse en los problemas
políticos internos tenía que ser el país
al que tenían que los países digamos
coquetearle para que las empresas
estadounidenses fueran invertir allí
ahora que estados unidos ha tomado
cierta distancia y que china hace más
esencia vemos a los países
latinoamericanos otra vez reclamando la
atención a eeuu descargándole un poco el
tema de la migración a eeuu que usted ya
lo dice no hay políticas internas
acertadas para manejar el tema y
volvemos entonces el círculo vicioso
necesitan a eeuu necesitan que invierta
pero critican que el país se meta en
invertir ya ayudar económicamente a los
estados latinoamericanos
la crítica es muy importante yo diría
que también en la región no sé hay una
fragmentación regional que realmente
nunca he visto en los últimos 30 o 40
años hay una falta de liderazgo de
coherencia y hay un deterioro en las
prácticas democráticas en muchos países
y se criticó mucho la exclusión de los
gobiernos autoritarios de la cumbre pero
nadie desde la región defendió la
democracia es algo creo el presidente
gabriel boric de chile
y la reacción no llegó a los ángeles con
una serie de propuestas o no no
necesariamente de demandas sino de
propuestas de lo que quería de los eeuu
entonces hay como es muy fácil quejar 6
es mucho más difícil plantear
concreto y viable así que criticó
bastante también a los presidentes y a
los líderes de la región eso es lo que
deben evidencia usted lo dice cynthia es
a esa fragmentación que hay en la región
los puntos de vista eran todos muy
dispares discrepancias entre los mismos
países manolo cómo hacer que lectura
puede hacer usted de esta coyuntura que
vivió américa latina en donde hay tantas
tantos puntos de vista distintos no hay
unión en las ideas cada país iba a
luchar por lo suyo y no se luchó como
región
creo que también esta debe ser la
fortaleza de la cumbre de las américas
debe en teoría por eso lo digo lo
recalco porque es cierto el que ha
cumbre las américas del tipo de
mecanismos sirve para crear una
heterogeneidad ideológica entre
latinoamérica y la américa anglosajona
este debe ser el puente de estos tipo de
mecanismos y por esos de odio hago tanto
hincapié en que debe ser necesario
invitar y no estudia cualquier a todos
los países porque porque a pesar es
cierto que existen esta fragmentación
ideológica y abusos y violaciones de
derechos humanos pero estos mecanismos
debe ser el escrutinio internacional
debe ser quien juzgue y quien condene
este tipo de violaciones hay demasiados
mecanismos hay demasiadas agendas
políticas y cada uno de los países como
tú dijiste santiago trae su propia
agenda entonces lo que sí debe debe
exigir existir debe ser a través del
multilateralismo a través del diálogo y
a través de la cooperación debemos de
atender las crisis que azotan a todo
nuestro continente entonces creo que sí
es cierto que la cumbre de las américas
se ve cada vez más existe un desinterés
se ve debilitada el presidente de byd en
a través de más allá de las buenas
intenciones que puede tener pues se ve
debilitado hacer una crítica del
gobierno de eeuu porque yo creo que ni
siquiera este juan gonzález que es este
consejero para el hemisferio norte del
consejo de seguridad de eeuu como el
secretario no tiene blinken yo creo que
han fracasado en establecer una política
regional para américa latina y
rápidamente porque lo digo porque a
pesar de que condena la dictadura de
maduro este condenó en la dictadura de
díaz canel estamos viendo cómo existen
tratados para temas energéticos en en
venezuela hay un reloj hay un
relajamiento para temas de viaje claro
en la habana pero a para ambas veces
este se excluye a estos países de estos
mecanismos que son fundamentales para
temas de migración de cambio climático y
de energía y finalmente también lo veo
también éste es hoy estelar verón está
hace unos días se le preguntaba a la
portavoz de la casa blanca que por qué
condenamos a dictaduras centroamericanas
y latinoamericanas como como nicaragua
como venezuela como cuba pero también
consideramos arabia saudí- común como un
socio clave en la región y básicamente
lo que contestó la portavoz de la casa
blanca fue que eeuu va a tener una
política siempre y cuando se adecue sus
propios intereses entonces
esperar cuando usted tiene este tipo de
ideología
cintia usted mencionaba en una de sus
intervenciones hablaba de una crisis de
liderazgo yo quisiera que ampliará ese
concepto de esa crisis de liderazgo en
la región y le añado otra crisis tal vez
depende de su punto de vista si hay una
crisis en la democracia en latinoamérica
en los liderazgos de los países y en las
construcciones de democracias en la
región quedó en evidencia en esta cumbre
en cómo se relacionaron los países para
llegar a esta cumbre
bueno es un poco difícil saber dónde
donde comenzar yo coincido plenamente
con
un
hipótesis de la pregunta que la
democracia ha deteriorado mucho en la
región tanto el respeto para la división
de poderes la como el respeto para la
prensa libre y la instó a las
instituciones de contrapeso
y esto es no comenzó con el cobre pero
se agudizó con el cobre y tiene que ver
con la el desencanto enorme de la
población latinoamericana que las
encuestas han mostrado
repetidamente el desencanto con el
funcionamiento de la democracia no como
el sistema como tal sino en
cómo los líderes se comportan que
entregan y yo vaya sabe muy bien que la
sobrevivencia de la democracia depende
mucho de su capacidad de resolver los
problemas básicos de la gente lo ha
dicho repetidamente
pero en lo económico
no vemos que hay recursos en esto a
cambio usted mencionó china los estados
unidos tienen pocos recursos
para invertir realmente para ayudar
a la recuperación económica de la región
y
la falta de liderazgo es justamente con
algo que manolo acabo de señalar durante
la pandemia todos los países se miraban
hacia adentro estaban intentando
responder a la crisis de salud pública
de la pandemia etcétera de la forma
posible y en estos dos años y medio casi
se ha
desaparecido
las esquemas de integración
en toda la región claro manolo algo que
decir de este quiebre de la integración
latinoamericana esta crisis del
liderazgo y esos vacíos que ha dejado
eeuu ya para esta recta final quiero
hablar de esa influencia de eeuu en la
región que se ha mermado se ha mermado
desde hace cuánto y le ha dado paso a
otros países como china ya lo
mencionamos turquía turquía como hay que
llamarlo ahora también ha aprovechado
para mejorar sus relaciones comercial es
con muchos países y también rusia no ha
perdido la oportunidad de tiene una
presencia comercial e importante y
política también en varios países y
ahora llegarán militares rusos a suelo
nicaragüense
porque también como mencionaba ciencia
creo que la pandemia ha venido a traer
este una recomposición primero para
empezar de las economías mundiales luego
el contexto internacional ya lo
mencionaba su sentido el tema de la
invasión de rusia el expansionismo y la
nueva corriente de gobiernos populistas
este tristemente de leer muchas veces de
la extrema derecha en europa en
centroamérica hoy vemos las noticias que
este ortega en nicaragua y le da la
bienvenida a tropas este rusas y todo
esto porque se crea pues por vacíos de
poder que va bien en estos vienen tienen
que ser llenados por distintos actores
hoy en día como lo mencionaba china
tiene una fuerte inversión en en
sudamérica a través de su nueva política
de la ruta de la seda entonces yo creo
que si existe lo que estamos viendo en
el continente que antes no lo veamos es
que el gobierno de eeuu está viendo
débil está viendo de vela a través de su
interior y de cara al continente y estos
estos espacios estos vacíos de poder van
a ser aprovechados por otros actores
tenemos yo lo entiendo también para bien
y para mal este rápidamente si vemos el
origen en el min 4 de la cumbre de las
américas fue concebida para para
consolidar la influencia de eeuu el
continente y creo que hoy en día lo que
sí ha hecho el gobierno mexicano y el
canciller ebrad y también presidente
lópez obrador fue que decir que esta
visión de que estos foros multilaterales
este fueron concebidos para únicamente
para servir los interés de los países
ricos ya son arcaicos y hay que quedar
en el pasado cada vez en un mundo más
interpolar esté más interconectado las
voces pesan entonces hay que tomar más
hay que dejar al lado la visión de que
no únicamente los países ricos son
aquellos que tienen injerencia en los
demás países sino solo la realidad de
todos los países cuentan y es lo que
estamos viendo hoy en día tal vez no nos
para no nos está apareciendo como se
está reconfigurando la visión el
escenario o el concierto internacional
donde eeuu países como eeuu la nueva ope
están perdiendo influencia pero otros
factores que antes no tenían voz ni voto
de igual manera que estos países están
emergiendo y eso hay que celebrarlo
ahora si las democracias y los órdenes
democráticos en distintos países y hay
que tener mucho cuidado porque están
haciendo una degradación de estos de
estos de de éstas
de estas democracias entonces hay que
atender estos problemas pero siempre hay
que cuidar nuestras democracias en la
región que quedan ya pocos minutos para
terminar el programa quiero cerrar
entonces con el tema de la influencia de
eeuu cynthia este primer paso dado por
washington para tratar de recuperar
entonces esta presencia en américa
latina' este papel de actor clave en la
región dará buenos resultados dado el
contexto internacional que nos describía
manolo el contexto de la guerra de
ucrania la presencia de rusia y la
fuerza económica que tiene china será
que le da resultado a eeuu
creo que tenemos que regresar al
principio de las cumbres no estoy de
acuerdo con lo que acaba de decir manolo
en que las cumbres fueron concebidas
para la imposición de los eeuu a la
región
si uno recuerden en el año 94 después de
la caída del muro de berlín el colapso
de la unión soviética
fue un mundo unipolar además en la
región todo los los países algo cuba
fueron democracias se había vivido la
transición de la dictadura a la
democracia entonces fue un momento
totalmente distinto a lo que existe
ahora
y durante los años 2000 especialmente
con el auge en el precio de los
commodities la compra de china
la influencia de china a través del
comercio
comprando los recursos básicos
especialmente de suramérica bueno
fue normal que los países de la región
querían diversificar sus relaciones
exteriores no solamente hacia el norte
sino a nuestros países como japón corea
del sur la india
o sea toda una gama no solamente de los
países autoritarios no creo que es un
vacío que los retiró de los eeuu ha
dejado sino parte de la progresión y el
progreso de la región en ciertos
aspectos en décadas pasadas me quedan ya
dos minutos para finalizar el programa
quiero llegar a entonces al punto de las
conclusiones sus puntos de vista e
impresiones de el cierre de todo esto lo
que vamos a ver hacia ante pensando en
estos acuerdos que fueron alcanzados en
este interés de eeuu de volverse a
acercar a la región que tan interesada
está de verdad la región en seguir
siendo tan cercana eeuu y más bien
pensar como lo explica cynthia en
diferentes actores de los cuales pueden
recibir inversiones con los cuales se
pueden relacionar a nivel político y
mejorar sus acuerdos comerciales
comienzos entonces con manolo para para
este cierre su conclusión
creo que a pesar de que ya mencionamos
que no fue lo que esperaba la cumbre las
américas creo que hay que seguir
apostando este tipo de mecanismos y de
multilateralismo creo que en estos
épocas de
recesión incluso económica venimos de la
pandemia venimos de un contexto tan
convulso en eeuu con la presidencia este
de trump hoy en día el presidente bayern
está apostando a desarrollar la región
una nueva relación con latinoamérica con
centroamérica y con su principal socio
comercial que es méxico este entonces
hay que celebrar esto y el tema
simplemente de la migración y de la
desigualdad en temas de latinoamérica
hay que decir atendiendo lo es un
problema regional y es una acción y es
una señal positiva que estoy tomando
cada vez más a todos los países para
actuar y no únicamente una sola visión
siente a su conclusión para el cierre
mi conclusión es que hay que dar mucho
seguimiento a lo que se escribió en el
papel durante la cumbre para ver qué
podría convertirse en realidad que no
sean únicamente una articulación de
principios de palabras lindas de nuevos
conceptos sino actos hechos concretos a
beneficio de la región y a beneficio de
los mismos intereses de los eeuu
pues a cintia ya manolo les agradezco
por haber hecho este análisis para la
audiencia de france 24 y tienen ustedes
los puntos de vista a ustedes también ya
tienen diferentes comentarios y puntos
de vista para ustedes sacar sus propias
conclusiones sobre este tema pueden
dejar sus comentarios y preguntas a
través de las redes sociales ya lo saben
les agradezco entonces esa ciencia ya
manolo por haber estado con nosotros y
ustedes también muchas gracias por la
sintonía pueden seguir viendo france24
siguen con nosotros
[Música]